well let's meet the girls shall we first
up please welcome April Ludgate
hello I'm April Ludgate
[Music]
I'm 20 years old
I like
people
places
and things and Pawnee is my favorite
place in the world
so I long for a day when women in
government will simply be seen as people
in government but until then I will work
to make Pawnee my wonderful Hometown as
good as it can be
what do you think I think you should
lose the first line and the last line
and all of the other lines and instead
just walk up to the mic and meow really
loudly for eight minutes okay so you're
from Mongolia team
will you take me with you when you go
back there
I love you
did you understand that
did you bring any Wolverines was your
name Jennifer no it's Jennifer with two
y's I used to be Jennifer but then I
decided to Rebrand myself
oh wait hang on it's on X o'clock
um
well nice to meet you my name's April
and I just wanted to say that your dress
is so cute it's Bonks I saw my spinning
instructor wearing it and I was like
shut up where do I get that oh my God
who's your spinning instructor Gregory
or Winona I go to Giannis who are
Gregory and Winona I've never heard of
them before are they better Winona rocks
my world seriously you need to get me in
there like that's a must must must she's
the worst person I've ever met
I want to travel the world with her
I'm going to do Impressions oh celebrity
Impressions that's that's wild
um this is an impression of my sister
hi I'm Natalie I love Ritalin and have
low self-esteem
[Laughter]
thank you
this is an impression of my boss Leslie
Knope
women should do everything check out my
four color pen hey everybody listen up
while I talk about some really really
important stuff practice practice
[Laughter]
okay folks just a couple more
contestants and then the judges will
decide our next Ms Pawnee a winner of
six hundred dollars in gift certificates
to Big Archie's sporting goods and
Emerson fencing company we don't get
cash this is for a fence well it won't
cover a whole fence but it will defray
the cost considerably oh my God
I quit
I quit
okay I guess she really is quitting no I
didn't win but at least I didn't make
any new friendships
I don't know why Leslie knobs on trial
and the Beavis did it okay beavers did
it
send gentlemen for the first time ever
in her new part-time job in the public
health department at City Hall
Africans yay oh Leslie this is so nice I
put the poisonous gas in one of these
balloons so if any of them pops you may
die okay are you ready for you to tell
me what's going on with Chris yes no to
sing if you're lost you can look and you
will find me
Time After Time go no tell me about
Chris if you fall I will catch you I'll
be waiting tell me about Chris or I'm
leaving and I don't care about the
letter
I want to have a baby and I asked Chris
to donate his sperm and he's taking a
really long time to make up his mind and
it's really freaking me out and I can't
stop thinking about it and I'm obsessing
about it I want to think about anything
else but that but it's making me crazy
Secrets stolen
[Music]
from deep inside you know this song
already of course I do everyone knows a
song that's amazing the drum beats out
of time if you're lost you can look and
you will find me find me Time After Time
if you fall I will catch you I will be
waiting
Time After Time Time After Time Time
After Time
it's never happened
[Music]
April come she will
when streams are ripe and swelled with
rain ladies and gentlemen we are
gathered here today to marry Andrew
Maxwell Dwyer and April Roberta Ludgate
I guess I
kind of hate most things but I never
really seem to hate you
so I want to spend the rest of my life
with you is that cool yes
babe you look more beautiful right now
than I've ever seen you
wow just your luck that you're going
into labor on Halloween can I get a warm
towel to get that makeup off no
whatever blows
babe my birth Max
here comes a contraction are you ready
okay I'm ready
[Music]
it caught on in a flag you know what I'm
gonna get that commission going because
this inequality has gone on long enough
you know what I think men are better
than women
she's kidding no I'm not they provide
for us and we must obey them because
they are our masters April stop it
Leslie You'll Never Land a bow with that
domineering tone
we must always walk behind the man I
believe one problem with hiring women is
that they're frail and breakable is it
possible you're thinking about light
bulbs or your hip if I were 300 years
older councilman
okay so I took extensive notes on ways
to maximize our efficiency because we
can't be just as good as the men we have
to be better yeah you're totally right
let's rock this April I love you but I
don't need your sarcasm right now I'm
serious let's get rolling I want to get
into some garbage
what I love garbage
you already found a dead body in the
trash or body parts a good torso or a
head please say head
[Music]
this is Stacy knobloch's house I went to
high school with her and she was super
mean to me and now I know that she dyes
her hair I knew that wedge wasn't
naturally blonde
oh my God
she has to use prescription strength
deodorant
this is the best day of my life
okay Leslie Knope outfit number eight
babe you look super hot you realize
you've said that about all of them well
she has every single time because she is
super hot honestly
you look hot naked oh the suit makes me
want to scold a Catholic child I don't
know who Ann Taylor is but I hate her
and I want to kill her I have to lead a
public forum for the Pawnee Commons
every day this week and I hate talking
to people
so to get through it I figured I'm just
gonna basically try to imitate Leslie
so where is this
she had the patch sewn in you can't
remove it what's in the pocket you ask a
ticket stub from a Fleetwood Mac concert
in 1995 and
this one is terrible but it is slightly
less terrible than the rest so tomorrow
I lead a public forum in Leslie's
Fleetwood Mac sex pants Fleetwood Mac
sex pants new band name I call it you
know what why don't we just say that
whoever gets to the emergency first will
be in charge okay so if there's an
explosion say in Ramset Park and someone
from sewage gets there first they'd be
in charge I had no idea how terrible
Leslie's job is she referred to this
meeting as a Non-Stop Thrill Ride I'm
not quite sure but Tom can answer that
if
what are you doing it's bouncing some
business ideas off Russell Simmons on
Twitter
why all due respect Miss lucky do you
even know what you're doing here all due
respect Mr hamster penis but no I don't
my last name is Giles are you sure
because you look like a hamster penis
what's your end game Here My Dear this
is only temporary until I find a way to
keep the shelter open without cutting
the Park's budget hey what if I threw
together a pet adoption in one of our
parks would that be cool April that
would be the coolest thing since NSYNC
Aerosmith and Nelly performed together
at the Super Bowl halftime show ew I
think I may have found a project I'd
actually enjoy doing
helping these cats and dogs they should
be rewarded for not being people I hate
people
so you do a lot of investing we like to
dabble recently invested in some shirts
I got at a garage sale left those at
Wendy's on the way home so the economy
[Laughter]